Caption: hello good afternoon how how is everyone
Caption: feeling after lunch sounds a bit sleepy
Caption: woof tough crowd so I have the great
Caption: pleasure of introducing Mac linearity
Caption: and Macklin's being incredibly
Caption: incredibly awesome with Dee Dee Dee
Caption: helping us to solve a huge amount of
Caption: issues on the front of our website as
Caption: well accessibility issues as well so and
Caption: in fact this is actually one of the
Caption: talks that I voted for as well so yeah
Caption: go dee dee dee
Caption: I don't know further ado had to overto
Caption: back lid thanks Rob good afternoon
Caption: everyone how great was lunch by the way
Caption: it was fantastic wasn't it delicious I'm
Caption: actually hoping you're all in a bit of a
Caption: food coma so you don't notice any of my
Caption: mistakes if I make them so it's great to
Caption: see so many people here here to hear me
Caption: ranting about my my talk every good
Caption: outage starts with a cue so let's get us
Caption: started first off what exactly is a cue
Caption: well you might remember cues from
Caption: various normal day-to-day activities
Caption: such as climbing Mount Everest or that
Caption: one time your engineering league got
Caption: stuck in the train and it was late for
Caption: work
Caption: or maybe that one super interesting and
Caption: riveting data structures unit that you
Caption: had in University house how cute is
Caption: actually pretty simple the first it's a
Caption: bit like the the Mount Everest q example
Caption: the first person in the queue actually
Caption: gets to see the top of the mountain
Caption: first and subsequent items in that queue
Caption: I join at the end and they have to wait
Caption: until they can be moved to the front of
Caption: the queue before they can get they can
Caption: get DQ'd at the end it is really quite
Caption: simple
Caption: I'm going to be talking specifically
Caption: about messaging keys which are
Caption: specifically for distributed messaging
Caption: systems so maybe I could get a little
Caption: bit of hands up who's used distributed
Caption: messaging before so something like
Caption: Amazon sqs for example or as you a
Caption: service bus RabbitMQ
Caption: or perhaps you like us we actually
Caption: rolled our own because it was fairly
Caption: simple for us so I hope I saw a lot of
Caption: hands up that gives me the impression
Caption: that I think developers actually quite
Caption: like use they had quite keen on them but
Caption: why exactly is that I can think of a
Caption: couple of reasons right so first of all
Caption: you they offer a really just a really
Caption: simple logical separation so the idea is
Caption: the message publisher the person who
Caption: publishes his message into the queue
Caption: they don't have to really understand how
Caption: the downstream processes are going to be
Caption: doing their job or in fact how many of
Caption: those downstream processes there are so
Caption: that's kind of nice on top of that they
Caption: can act like a bit of a shock absorber
Caption: so they can iron out the effects of
Caption: getting a whole lot of traffic all at
Caption: once
Caption: and that will ultimately make your
Caption: system much more responsive lastly and
Caption: this this is more important for us they
Caption: offer this you know kind of persistence
Caption: mechanism so we store our all our
Caption: messages indefinitely in the queues that
Caption: we build and that will allow us to later
Caption: on we could reprocess that data to gain
Caption: new insights and get new information out
Caption: of that so I'm going to talk a little
Caption: bit now about the system that I've been
Caption: working on lately that does use queues
Caption: so what we have here to begin with is
Caption: there was a third part of party system
Caption: and they were sending messages on to
Caption: consumers various internal consumers
Caption: internal systems that we also have none
Caption: of this is our stuff what we wanted to
Caption: introduce in the middle was a message
Caption: proxy that could listen to these
Caption: messages
Caption: maybe store them and maybe later on we
Caption: could process that information later on
Caption: for to gain insights from like I
Caption: described before in this example here
Caption: our consumers have turned into the
Caption: tenants of this message proxy system
Caption: so the problem here is if we do this
Caption: naively and the message proxy receives a
Caption: message from this the external third
Caption: party what happens if we fail to send
Caption: that message on to our tenon so that we
Caption: could just drop that message on the
Caption: floor but then the the tenant would
Caption: never receive that data and that's a
Caption: potential loss of data which is not
Caption: really what we want I guess the other
Caption: thing we could do here is stop and wait
Caption: a little bit and retry it and hope that
Caption: it works but what happens if that tenant
Caption: is down for like five minutes we can't
Caption: keep this request open for five minutes
Caption: that's just not going to work either so
Caption: what we decided to do was introduce a
Caption: queue now the queue is the orange thing
Caption: in the middle and what happens now is
Caption: the message from the third party system
Caption: is received and we immediately store it
Caption: and we can return a response straight
Caption: away after that a process manager is
Caption: picking up these messages off the top of
Caption: the queue one by one and it will send
Caption: that message on to our tenant the great
Caption: thing here is if that tenant is down and
Caption: we fail to send that message we can just
Caption: wait and retry without keeping requests
Caption: open because the process manager is in a
Caption: different process so it's worth noting
Caption: here that we were very confident about
Caption: this system I'm actually the the the
Caption: diagrams I had here represent a very
Caption: small man of the system we had actually
Caption: tons of process managers I was just
Caption: trying to keep it simple but we were
Caption: quite confident that we'd built
Caption: something that was resilient and would
Caption: scale pretty well and we were probably
Caption: very close to learning that at this
Caption: point that we were actually probably a
Caption: little bit cocky is the way I describe
Caption: it we built a system but we've done it
Caption: quite naively and I'm about to go into
Caption: some lessons that we've learned in our
Caption: process so the first lesson we learned
Caption: was that observability and monitoring
Caption: are absolutely essential if you're
Caption: building any sort of distributed system
Caption: so many monitoring tools these days are
Caption: actually fantastic without much
Caption: configuration they can tell us lots of
Caption: details about the web layer they come
Caption: with default configurations usually for
Caption: the web layer and they can tell us stuff
Caption: like our average response time how many
Caption: errors were getting and this thing
Caption: called app stack scores which I don't
Caption: fully understand but that's in there as
Caption: well however when we set up her
Caption: monitoring because these tools were
Caption: configured to their defaults we actually
Caption: neglected to think about the metrics
Caption: that were directly related to the
Caption: performance of these queues one that we
Caption: found was actually particularly
Caption: important at least for us was a metric
Caption: called queue depth so queue depth is
Caption: basically the number of messages behind
Caption: in the queue your process managers are
Caption: compared to the top of the queue so as
Caption: you can see here we were finding that we
Caption: were recording occasional very large
Caption: spikes in our queue depth at its peak
Caption: there it's about 8,000 or just under but
Caption: there that was never to the to the
Caption: detriment of our response times whenever
Caption: queue depth rises it takes a long time
Caption: for messages to be received because our
Caption: queues have to actually catch up and
Caption: that causes delays this actually for us
Caption: represented an outage of over 40 minutes
Caption: which was not not a great outcome so the
Caption: second lesson we learned was that it's
Caption: important to learn and understand the
Caption: true throughput of your system
Caption: throughput was actually really big issue
Caption: for us in general and going back to the
Caption: system that we were working on we
Caption: identified that only some of the
Caption: messages that we were receiving even
Caption: though they all looked the same some of
Caption: them were important enough they did they
Caption: needed to be delivered as soon as
Caption: possible and the rest but there was
Caption: never any detriment to any delay in
Caption: sending those messages so what we did to
Caption: combat that as we chose to put these
Caption: messages into two different queues and
Caption: they'd have two different process
Caption: managers that could process them in in
Caption: concurrently but now we have twice as
Caption: many queues
Caption: that should mean we fixed our q-tip
Caption: there she's right we've turned this into
Caption: a concurrent process we can have two
Caption: processes firing twice as many messages
Caption: to our tenant it's faster now right well
Caption: probably not unfortunately
Caption: so it pays to think about cues a bit
Caption: like leaky buckets the bucket gets
Caption: filled from the top with messages and it
Caption: can get filled very quickly and then
Caption: messages are drained at the bottom
Caption: through the small hole that you can see
Caption: there it's possible to fill this bucket
Caption: up much quicker than the bucket is
Caption: actually draining out our keys were able
Caption: to ingest roughly 2,000 messages per
Caption: minute but we found out later through
Caption: through measuring this stuff that our
Caption: messages per minute going out that the
Caption: messages that we were able to produce
Caption: was only roughly 500 this is what this
Caption: calls the the buckets to fill up very
Caption: quickly now and it's important to think
Caption: maybe you can think of a queue depth for
Caption: example as how full this bucket is at
Caption: any given time so deciding to put in a
Caption: second queue a high priority queue and a
Caption: low product you is it actually a bit
Caption: like adding a second bucket so now we
Caption: can process a thousand messages per
Caption: minute great that's fantastic but we can
Caption: also ingest twice as many as we could
Caption: before so we've not actually solved any
Caption: problem here
Caption: not to mention nothing was really
Caption: guaranteeing us at this point that we
Caption: wouldn't fill one bucket exclusively so
Caption: nothing was stopping us from receiving a
Caption: high volume of load of these high
Caption: priority messages and just having the
Caption: same problem that we started with so
Caption: measuring the limits of our queues was
Caption: actually very valuable to us we learned
Caption: that adding more queues didn't
Caption: necessarily equate to more throughput
Caption: unfortunately we've actually solved our
Caption: problem at least for 99% of the time the
Caption: high product key is working for us well
Caption: but unfortunately it was never going to
Caption: be enough to protect us from a high load
Caption: so on to the last lesson that we learn
Caption: and that is understanding how the
Caption: external factors of the system can
Caption: impact your throughput so going back to
Caption: how our processes managers worked what
Caption: they did is they were DQ one message at
Caption: a time one another time and they would
Caption: forward that message on to our tenant
Caption: and that was actually through HTTP we
Caption: measured how long that entire process
Caption: took and we learned that it was about
Caption: 150 to 200 milliseconds doing a bit of
Caption: calculation based on that number we can
Caption: calculate that it should be able to
Caption: process around 500 messages per minute
Caption: and that was actually more than enough
Caption: for our general load we did load testing
Caption: to confirm this but most of the time
Caption: that was perfectly fine for us but what
Caption: would happen if our tenants their
Caption: response time significantly increased
Caption: what if the response time actually
Caption: jumped up to somewhere between 2 & 5
Caption: seconds I sounds oddly specific because
Caption: this is something that actually happened
Caption: to us exactly this so when we
Caption: recalculate with this in mind we
Caption: actually have a message straight that
Caption: wrote rate that significantly drops to
Caption: only about 30 messages per minute the
Caption: response time was actually also fairly
Caption: erratic
Caption: so it was jumping up to I was often
Caption: jumping up to more than 5 seconds that
Caption: made the calculations much less reliable
Caption: as well 30 messages per minute was never
Caption: going to be enough to to cover our
Caption: general load as well so that was not
Caption: good so why exactly does this happen
Caption: well one big reason is because our
Caption: system is using sequential our queues so
Caption: the only way to get sequential messages
Caption: messages one after the other to our mind
Caption: was to perform the to send those
Caption: messages through sequential queues to
Caption: perform as messages one after the other
Caption: something that I've been thinking about
Caption: for a while is that trying to do this
Caption: sequential queueing is probably a little
Caption: bit naive
Caption: putting such a restriction around these
Caption: cues made them easier for us to
Caption: conceptualize and validate and and test
Caption: and it was a lot clearer and there's a
Caption: lot of value in that in terms of
Caption: building a distributed system because
Caption: that system was already really complex
Caption: like I said before we had lots of these
Caption: process managers and was all very
Caption: complicated so it was nice of these
Caption: these were easy to quite like to
Caption: visualize but ultimately that limitation
Caption: alone caused us all sorts of headaches
Caption: for throughput what it really means is
Caption: the only way to think about beginning to
Caption: fix this is to start thinking about how
Caption: we could process these many messages
Caption: concurrently so we tried a few things
Caption: first thing we did was batching so this
Caption: is similar to what we had before we were
Caption: still going to be sending one request
Caption: after the other but instead of that
Caption: request containing one message why
Caption: wouldn't it contain a hundred messages
Caption: then we could send stuff a lot faster
Caption: unfortunately something weird happened
Caption: here it turns out the response time at
Caption: the tenon increased the the larger
Caption: number of messages that we sent and that
Caption: was just something that was out of our
Caption: control was up to the implementation on
Caption: the other side and ultimately this had
Caption: zero effect on the throughput obviously
Caption: so we were still sending roughly 50
Caption: messages per minute and honestly the
Caption: response time was about 50 seconds so
Caption: that was never going to work in the real
Caption: world the next thing we tried is
Caption: something that we came up with that we
Caption: came up with the name for it I don't
Caption: know if there is a known for this but we
Caption: called it fan-out and ultimately this is
Caption: similar again to what we have in our
Caption: current process there's just one process
Caption: but the idea is that will fan out to
Caption: multiple threads and try to send those
Caption: messages concurrently if it could it
Caption: would then wait for all of those
Caption: messages to be sent before continuing on
Caption: and if any of them failed it would be
Caption: able to retry the result there was
Caption: actually pretty good it was a lot faster
Caption: we were looking at roughly 4,000
Caption: messages per minute
Caption: another implementation that we we
Caption: haven't had a lot of chance to look at
Caption: yet is sharding so going back to that
Caption: bucket analogy sharding is is a bit like
Caption: adding lots and lots of buckets but the
Caption: difference here is that we can guarantee
Caption: that an even distribution of messages
Caption: well will land in each one of those
Caption: buckets we're hoping we're still
Caption: experimenting with this but we're hoping
Caption: that this is faster still just because
Caption: this will be leveraging lots like will
Caption: be scaled out to lots of process
Caption: managers and will be leveraging that
Caption: computer a lot better so what do we
Caption: learn today well it's important to think
Caption: about how you'll observe and monitor
Caption: your queues think about the metrics in
Caption: particular that are directly related to
Caption: queue performance such as queue depth
Caption: understand the throughput and the load
Caption: limitations of your systems make sure
Caption: you get accurate measurements and
Caption: understand the maximum throughput of
Caption: your process managers and keys and think
Caption: about queues a bit like leaky buckets if
Caption: that helps
Caption: and lastly learn the behavior of your
Caption: external systems I make sure you
Caption: understand how that has an effect on
Caption: your keys so don't make assumptions
Caption: about how your external dependencies
Caption: will behave
Caption: maybe measure and and try to understand
Caption: what happens if that behavior does
Caption: change because ultimately it could it
Caption: did to us
Caption: so queues are often a great tool and I
Caption: have many many usages but and as well
Caption: often they're the perfect solution to a
Caption: particular problem as well but
Caption: it's really important to understand that
Caption: they have their limitations
Caption: I think queues are a really powerful
Caption: tool but they're only powerful when they
Caption: use thoughtfully and if they use naively
Caption: they can cause you all sorts of issues
Caption: so that's it for me I've actually
Caption: finished a little bit early but that's a
Caption: fine I'd like to thank the team at ddd
Caption: perth i think this is actually truly a
Caption: great conference fantastic community
Caption: everything I've actually tended for a
Caption: number of years and it's actually a
Caption: really awesome privilege to be able to
Caption: speak it this one I'm really really
Caption: stoked about that I'm gonna do a little
Caption: plug cuz I've got a time now I guess I
Caption: work for let's see if I can get this oh
Caption: for these guys here vgw
Caption: it's a great place to work if you want
Caption: to have lots of opportunities to learn
Caption: from like amazing senior developers and
Caption: if you're interested in tackling
Caption: problems like this like large scale and
Caption: using the latest technologies I I work
Caption: with kubernetes day-to-day which is
Caption: fantastic and we use all sorts of other
Caption: cutting-edge stuff you can make the team
Caption: they're running the coffee cart sort of
Caption: down the back on the opposite end of the
Caption: theater or you can have a chat with me
Caption: after so yeah that's it for me
Caption: I'm not taking questions because well I
Caption: say here there's not enough time but
Caption: yeah there's enough time I'm not taking
Caption: questions but you can reach out to me on
Caption: Twitter if you like or you can catch me
Caption: at the coffee cart I might wait around
Caption: there after there if you want to talk to
Caption: me or if you're coming to the after
Caption: party just just come and say hi thank
Caption: you very much
Caption: [Applause]